les paysages majestueux et l'air frais
même en ville ce qui frappe en
Nouvelle-Zélande c'est ce qu'on ne voit
presque nulle part la cigarette le pays
compte déjà un des plus faibles taux de
fumeurs de la planète 8% dans la
population en général mais près de 20%
chez les maorilles Autochtones la
Nouvelle-Zélande veut réduire cette
disparité et devenir un endroit sans
fumer d'ici deux ans
paquets par semaine à un seul bon
mélange les hausses vertigineuses des
taxes sur le tabac depuis 2010 ne
suffisait plus la Nouvelle-Zélande à
adopter en décembre des lois drastiques
pour réduire le taux de nicotine dans
les produits du tabac interdire à tout
jamais aux personnes nées après 2008
d'acheter du tabac et éliminer 90% des
points de vente d'ici deux ans
ce commerçant pour qui le tabac
représente 30% de son chiffre d'affaires
ne s'est pas encore s'il devra cesser
d'en vendre
mais il croit que les propriétaires de
dépanneurs seront presque tous forcés de
trouver d'autres sources de revenus
la génération visée est celle de ses
filles qui se retrouvent pour la
baignade chaque après-midi elles ont
entre 13 et 15 ans
elles affirment le moqueur qu'ils n'ont
jamais fumé
de toute façon ce n'est pas la cigarette
qui attire les jeunes en
Nouvelle-Zélande c'est le vapotage ce
sera d'ailleurs la prochaine cible de
mesure contraignantes lorsque le pays
sera sans tabac le taux de vapotage il
est légèrement supérieur au tabagisme en
ce moment et en pleine croissance car
les produits sont beaucoup moins taxés
public ou mesure drastiques pour
atteindre l'objectif d'une
Nouvelle-Zélande sans fumée est élevée
même si certains affirment qu'il s'agit
probablement d'une entorse aux libertés
individuelle peut-être
la santé semble être une priorité
partagée par beaucoup de citoyens comme
cette femme qui veut protéger son
petit-fils
si certains politiciens et commerçants
brandissent la menace d'une augmentation
de la contrebande des experts rappels
que la Nouvelle-Zélande est un archipel
il croit donc le marché noir peut plus
facilement être enrayé aux frontières
ici Philippe leblanca retour au roi en
Nouvelle-Zélande